évent la démonstration chez avec da
arrange parce qu'il est passé ce soir
prendre un café donc s'il me sert à
faire la démonstration
vous vous souvenez de marange j'avais
fait une vidéo avec toi je la mette au
dessus de nous comme ça vous pourrez
cliquer dessus je vous en reparle à la
fin on va faire la démonstration de ce
que j'aurai expliqué dans la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui parfaite et donc tu penses
à une carte c'est bon c'est bon je pense
qu'ils pensent qu'ils pensent qu'ils
l'oublient pas c'est fait ok donc tu
m'aider moi comme ça et alors tu dois
être le plus détendu possible tu vois
voilà c'est moi qui n'accompagne pas le
mouvement c'est vraiment moi qui gère
tes mains ok ok on va faire un truc
cette malle à la une bague dit wak elle
correspond au oui
d'abord parce que le oui tu vois c'est
la bague août a dit oui ok ça y'a pas de
bac c'est le nom ok donc j'ai déposé de
plein de questions mais en vrai ce sont
des affirmations et à chaque fois que
j'affirme quelque chose dans ta tête tu
pense oui ou non
mais au delà dit penser tu envoies toute
ton énergie mentale vers la réponse donc
si tu pense oui tu te concentres
mentalement sur sept mois ce que tu
penses non tu te concentres mentalement
sur cette maroc
est-ce que c'est clair c'est clair très
clair alors on commence avec des choses
simples et tu dis toujours oui ou non
dans ta tête à la fin de concentrant sur
une dès demain ok je m'appelle fabien
donc ça c'est oui ok d'accord tu
t'appelles barange tu portes un
tee-shirt noir et pour que tu vérifies
continuer toujours oui et toujours non
auquel nous sommes à paris
nous sommes à bordeaux nous sommes à
nantes hockey qui pense toujours à ta
carte ça peut être du pique niqueurs car
au titre f ok mais c'est un carton rouge
assez correct est correct ça qu'est bon
je pense l'avoir pense toujours à ta
carte
je pense à ma carte ça peut être une
carte à points ça peut être une figure
paul figure ça donc je vous le dis aux
jeunes là je ressens une petite
résistance quand il s'est concentré sur
le nom d'ailleurs avec un tout petit ans
d'écart je crois dans ce jour à dakar
je pense donc tu te pense toujours au
nom quand c'est non et aux huit ans et
oui je vais tout les dire ok ta carte ça
peut être un as 1,2 1,3 1,4
à 5 1 6 1 7 5 1 6 1 7 à 8
ok c'est le site de carros exact y est
elle existe des carreaux alors c'est
vrai qu'il est arrivé j'ai déjà fait les
explications donc tu regarderas la vidéo
demain cela fera exactement comment ça
se passe
ouais parce que j'ai rien vu encore mais
sauf que là contrairement à l'autre jour
où je faisais que bluffé là en fait
c'est vraiment pour que vous puissiez le
reproduire avec les explications et au
moins vous m'avez vu faire sur baranger
ça c'est cool quoi en tout cas j'ai vu
ta dernière vidéo mec c'est une tuerie
je savais pas si j'allais vous voyez
vous pas là je vais vous mettre un bien
non pas aussi vers la vidéo qu'on a fait
ensemble mais encore plus intéressant en
fait oublier la vidéo qu'on a fait
ensemble sur ma chaîne plus intéressant
que ça vous allez voir la dernière vidéo
qu'il a sorti c'est une vidéo qui a été
réalisé par quelqu'un sur sa vie ça dure
deux minutes
tefana la fin voilà sinon merci fabien
tu es au top je vais te vous voyez merci
et moi je te fais un gros et je vais
créer des nouveaux comptes youtube pour
ma bosse ce mec est une star il faut
s'abonner albi c'est comme ça merci mon
poste de tenir s'ils retournent cool
merci et rendez vous demain à 17 heures
ciao